[Musica]
quando andavo nel laboratorio di mio
padre vedevo dei piattini sui banconi
quei piattini contenevano colonie di
batteri e mi facevano pensare a una
città con molti
abitanti in ogni batterio C'è un re
molto lungo e molto magro il re ha molti
servitori robusti e corti simili a delle
sfere mio padre chiama il re DNA e i
servitori enzimi il re è come un libro
nel quale viene segnata ogni cosa che de
essere fatta dai servitori per noi
esseri umani queste istruzioni sono un
mistero Mio padre ha scoperto un
servitore che si comporta come un paio
di forbici se un re straniero invade un
batterio questo servitore può tagliarlo
in piccoli
frammenti ma senza fare del mare al
proprio re Gente in gamba usa il
servitore con le forbici per scoprire i
segreti del re per fare questo riunisce
molti servi con le forbici e li mette
sul Re così il re viene fatto a pezzi e
scoprire i segreti di ogni piccolo pezzo
diventa più facile per questo motivo mio
padre ha ricevuto il premio Nobel per la
scoperta dei servitori con le
forbici può quindi un paio di forbici
cambiare il mondo sì se sono fatte così
Bam Questa è una coppia di enzimi una
destra una sinistra delle proteine che
compiono una reazione in questo caso
tagliano la trama che è costituita dai
filamenti di DNA ed è uno dei Servi con
le forbici di cui vi ho appena parlato
con le parole di Silvia harber oggi
neurobiologa allora bambina figlia di
Werner harber che ha vinto il premio
Nobel per aver scoperto gli enzimi di
restrizione ovvero questi servi con le
forbici questo in particolare è stato
isolato da un batterio che si chiama
bacillus Amilo liquefaction e per gli
amici questo enzima si chiama Bam
H1 Mi servo spesso di questo enzima
diventando io il re in quanto Vado a
tagliare il DNA in piccoli frammenti
quindi il DNA è un re ormai
spodestato in questo modo possiamo
andare a tagliare in maniera specifica
il DNA ma lo sappiamo il DNA in realtà è
una trama anchesso la trama del grande
gioco della vita e lo sappiamo il DNA
contiene geni che come parole possono
Codificare per proteine dando
l'istruzione alla cellula su come fare
le stesse proteine e tutto il resto ok
ma io posso prendere queste parole e
copio incollarle in un altro file come
farei il computer
Sì se sei in qualche modo in grado di
isolarlo come quando noi evidenziamo al
computer entrano qui in gioco i servi
con le forbici non c'è solo Bam H1 ce ne
sono tante ma Ognuno taglia in una
sequenza specifica del DNA mentre
ignorano tutto il resto otteniamo quindi
dei pezzettini che però hanno delle
estremità che spuntano fuori che sono
specifiche a seconda dell'enzima con le
forbici che l'ha tagliato e si possono
incollare solo ad altre estremità
tagliate dallo stesso enzima in questo
modo in una provetta possiamo avere
tanti pezzettini di DNA che si incollano
fra loro in una certa sequenza specifica
come se fossero tessere di un puzzle e
non importa quale sia l'origine di
questo DNA può derivare da un animale da
una pianta da un microorganismo essere
fatto da una
macchina Beh questo fa la biologia
sintetica per esempio arrivando a
ottenere delle chimere dei costrutti che
in natura non esistono e insieme
all'ingegneria genetica possiamo
ottenere degli organismi
geneticamente modificati particolarmente
utili che già stanno rivoluzionando
molti settori per esempio per produrre
farmaci o I sostituti della plastica ma
siccome le trame della ricerca si
infittiscono sempre di più a un certo
punto è arrivata questa cosa
qui il sistema
crisper
alcuni enzimi con le forbici come per
esempio cas9 in grado di legare il DNA e
Bam tagliarlo però per farlo ha bisogno
di essere telecomandato lì e quindi noi
possiamo fornirgli un pezzo di RNA a cui
si lega cas9 che ha una sequenza
specifica per un certo una certa
porzione il DNA Ma attenzione Il DNA di
una cellula viva quindi il suo possiamo
andare a intervenire sul genoma di una
cellula viva Non più soltanto in una
provetta quindi essenzialmente cas9 con
l' RNA si presentano sul DNA come una
coppia quasi a dire lui è il gatto ed io
la volpe siamo in società di noi ti puoi
fidare E invece casd
Bam taglia senza
pietà Vatti a fidare di questi enzimi eh
vè Ok ma io cioè cosa me ne faccio di un
pezzo rotto adesso per di più una
cellula Viva la cellula in tutti i modi
cerca di riparare il danno e noi come i
peggiori opportunisti dopo aver causato
il danno gli diamo anche la soluzione
Eccoti qui un bel pezzo di DNA fiammante
che guarda casa assomiglia proprio al
pezzo in cui ti abbiamo appena causato
il danno Certo poi ha un pezzo di DNA in
più o qualcosa di diverso una mutazione
qui una mutazione là ma che vuoi che sia
fai il contratto e vedrà
che non ti pentirai in questo modo
possiamo Sì inserire un gene esterno
derivante da un altro organismo oppure
anche sostituirne uno interno facendone
soltanto una piccola
mutazione può sembrare poco ma questo ha
già
rivoluzionato settori interi come
l'agricoltura noi scopriamo Talenti e
non sbagliamo mai noi sapremo sfruttare
le tue
qualità Beh Noi siamo i biotecnologi
ricercatori scienziati che utilizzano
esser viventi O parti di esso per
ottenere dei prodotti di interesse
commerciale che Detto così sembra
orribile Eh però in realtà sono processi
Biotech anche la produzione del pane e
della birra perché come protagonista
abbiamo un essere vivente solo che è
invisibile non lo vediamo un
microorganismo è il lievito
io per lavoro utilizzo questi lieviti
che per me sono degli operai
instancabili Ma come capo della fabbrica
mi occupo anche della loro formazione e
quindi fornisco loro nuovo sapere nuova
conoscenza sotto forma di DNA che è
essenzialmente una molecola che contiene
informazioni in questo modo diventano
OGM che sono in grado di fare delle
reazioni che altrimenti non avrebbero
mai saputo fare prima in realtà ognuna
di queste Cellole è anche una piccola
fabbrica perché è in grado di
trasformare delle materie prime in
molecole utili in molti settori e la
materia prima principale sono delle
biomasse ovvero del materiale
principalmente vegetale di conseguenza
origine rinnovabile al contrario delle
Fonti fossili che sappiamo non essere
minimamente rinnovabili nei tempi
compatibili col loro utilizzo ol al
fatto che sono inquinanti e hanno un
sacco di problemi che sappiamo Ma
attenzione queste biomasse in realtà
sono anche lo stipendio dei miei operai
Perché di fatto contengono spesso
zuccheri che sono il cibo dei miei
microrganismi Ah il lievito adora gli
zuccheri proprio se li mangia alla
grande E io come capo della fabbrica mi
devo ovviamente anche occupare di
trovare lo stipendio per i miei operai e
quindi come fonte di zucchero Sarebbe
facile utilizzare il mais o la canna da
zucchero ma sarei in competizione con il
settore alimentare Quindi è meglio
andarmi a procacciare del cibo delle
biomasse a basso costo per esempio che
siano dei sottoprodotti o degli avanzi
di altri settori come quello
agroalimentare il più diffuso è
cosiddetta lig
Cellulosa tipo il legno che non è che
sembra molto appetibile effettivamente
ma gli zuccheri presenti all'interno di
queste biomasse lign cellulosiche sono
intrappolate dalle trame costruite dalle
piante per fortuna abbiamo dei Servi con
le forbici in grado di tagliare anche
gli zuccheri liberando quindi le unità
zuccherine che diventano lo stipendio
per i miei
microrganismi Quindi per una trama di
DNA e zuccherina che viene rotta se ne
può creare un'altra di DNA e un'altra di
processo all'interno per esempio delle
bioraffinerie ovvero dei processi che si
basano sulle biomasse Con lo scopo di
sostituire in tutto in parte I processi
che invece si basano sulle raffinerie
che partono dalle risorse fossili io per
lavoro di ricerca lavoro proprio nello
sviluppo di bioprocess bioraffinerie che
si Basino su biomasse residuali da un
lato e su microorganismi geneticamente
modificati o meno nei miei 10 anni di
ricerca presso l'Università Milano
Bicocca ho sviluppato dei bioprocess per
produrre biocarburanti bioplastiche
farmaci vitamine coloranti additivi per
mangimi dei pesci tutto vero in questo
senso la biodiversità che c'è là fuori è
per noi
un'enorme biblioteca da cui attingere
biomasse microrganismi e
Geni l'ultimo messaggio che vi voglio
portare riguarda la bioeconomia ovvero
quel settore dell'economia che riguarda
la valorizzazione delle biomasse sembra
una cosa strana ma in realtà è la nostra
quotidianità perché all'interno abbiamo
settori che vanno dal quello alimentare
ai detersivi passando per i
biocarburanti e il tessile però
purtroppo spesso queste realtà non si
parlano ed è davvero un peccato perché
potrebbero creare delle trame per
ottenere dei nuovi processi virtuosi e
anche creare nuove opportunità di lavoro
essendo stato nominato Eu bioeconomy
Youth Ambassador dalla Commissione
Europea Ho un ultimo messaggio finale
che riguarda le biotecnologie e la
bioeconomia per voi per le aziende e per
la
politica non vedi che è un vero affare
non perdere
l'occasione
Grazie
[Applauso]
n